j'ouvre le second débat de ce sens
public et on va rester sur ce thème
consacré à la guerre qui fait rage entre
Israël et le Hamas tsal parle de combat
féroce aujourd'hui et Benjamin netanahou
a rejeté toute idée de cesser le feu
selon le Premier ministre israélien ce
serait je le cite une capitulation audre
vetaz à Gaza les combats au sol font
rage entre l'armée israélienne et le
Hamas c'est aussi une guerre d'imagees
qui se poursuit sur ces vidéos fournies
par Tsahal ces militaires progressent
dans les ruines du territoire
palestinien le porte-parole de l'armée
affirme que 3 sensibles militaires du
Hamas ont été frappés ces dernières 24
heures la branche armée du Hamas elle
diffuse des vidéos de ses combattants
sortant de son réseau de tunnel armé de
lance-roquette selon leur dire ils
auraient tendu des guettapan aux soldats
israéliens des combats qui devraient
durer le Premier ministre israélien
Benjamin netaniaou rejette les demandes
de CC le feu de plus en plus nombreuse
de la part de la communauté
internationale au 25e jour de la guerre
la situation humanitaire dans la bande
de Gaza inquiète vivement sous le feu
des bombardements alors que l'enclave
est soumise à un blocus ses habitants de
Rafa enterre leur mort et en appelle à
l'aide
internationale nous demandons au monde
entier de faire preuve de compassion
envers les enfants pour mettre fin à ces
massacres et les propriétaires des
maisons sont innocents il n'y avait pas
de combattants à l'intérieur
la guerre qui s'étend hors de Gaza en 6
Jordanie l'armée israélienne affirment
avoir fait exploser la maison d'un
commanditaire des attaques sanglantes du
7 octobre hors des frontières les
rebelles du Yémen proches de l'Iran se
mêlent au conflit ils affirment avoir
lancé des drones en direction d'Israël
et promettent de continuer pour soutenir
le Hamas
palestinien on analyse lesffet majeurs
de ce 25e jour de guerre avec Pascal
Boniface bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
géopolitologue fondateur directeur de
l'iris l'Institut de relations
internationales et stratégiqu et auteur
de géostrateggic 2 les grands enjeux du
monde contemporain c'est publié chez
dunom on est dans la vulgarisation des
enjeux de de géopolitique et c'est
important Alexandra schwarzbord bonsoir
et bienvenue vous êtes directrice
adjointe de la rédaction de de
libération ancienne correspondante du
journal à Jérusalem c'est au début des
années 2000 offer Bronstein bonsoir et
bienvenue président du Forum
international pour la paix et la
réconciliation au Proche Orient et vous
êtes chargé de mission auprès d'Emmanuel
Macron pour le rapprochement des
sociétés israéliennes et palestinienne
et puis vous allez aussi on va s'appuyer
sur votre expérience vous étiez au
cabinet derabine pendant de longues
années çarabine qui avait été assez
longue assassiné en
1995 et on parlera de la difficulté de
faire naître un processus de paix dans
cette région évidemment la dernière
information de cette fin d'après-midi de
mardi c'est cette annonce euh du
porte-parole de la branche militaire du
Hamas qui affirme que le mouvement allit
va libérer dans les prochains jours des
otages étrangers voilà la citation
exacte nous avons informé les
intermédiaires que nous libérerons un
certain nombre d'étrangers dans les
prochains jour on est évidemment aussi
dans une guerre
informationnelle mais quand même
qu'est-ce qu'il y a derrière cette
information cette annonce Pascal
Boniface comment vous vous l'analysez un
ramasse qui joue un peu entre guillemets
je mets plein de guillemets le chaud et
le froid oui effectivement B qui essaent
de mettre un peu une lueur d'espoir pour
les familles des otages pour faire
pression sur les pour mettre fin au
bombardement ou diminuer l'intensité des
B sur Gaza donc c'est promettre quelque
chose pour dans plusieurs jours afin de
gagner peut-être un peu de temps et un
peu d'espace aussi et donc de d'espérer
avoir une des bonbardant moins intensif
mais je doute que cela soit le résultat
obtenu ouis et et d'ailleurs il y avait
auour aujourd'hui plusieurs otages
notamment des otages français
franco-israéliens qui sont en France qui
viennent communiquer il y a une
conférence de presse aexand scharzbord
est-ce que ça pèse sur les décisions du
cabinet de guerre la le le sort des
otages israélien d'abord mais aussi
multinationaux je nen suis pas si sûr
encore que ce qu'il faut bien savoir ce
qui nous nous paraît fou mais ça existe
en parallèle des opérations militaires
donc très on les a
vu enfin je dire très violente oui c'est
sans doute la journée la plus la plus
violente du si c'est possible parce que
c'est tous les jours c'est c'est une
violence inédite sur sur Gaza et en
parallèle de tout ça il y a des
négociations qui sont qui ont lieu
notamment au Qatar pour essayer
justement de libérer des otages donc sur
ce plan-là c'est vrai que Israël ne
lâche pas essaye de négocier euh avec le
Qatar au Qatar et et tout en bombardant
massivement donc si vous voulez il
Israël joue sur les deux tableaux parce
que évidemment pour Benjamin netaniaahou
ce serait ce serait arrivé à sauver des
otages ce serait ça ajouterait un peu de
crédit lui qui a tout perdu qui est est
très affaibli politiquement dans son pay
il non seulement affaibli mais il est il
est il est détesté Hai par par grand un
grand nombre d'Israélien et là peut-être
il se dit que peut-être s'il arrivait à
en sortir quelques-uns vivants h il
pourrait peut-être sauver un tout petit
peu mais voilà je suis même pas sûr que
ça que ça suffise à à à rétablir son
crédit tout en bombardant massivement
parce que lui de toute façon il ne
connaît que ça Benyamin netanahou c'est
la force la force la force ferbine il y
a dans les proposition du ramas cet
échange
otage contre prisonniers palestiniens
est-ce que ça ça il y a pas eu de
réponse je crois officielle de de de
netaniahou du cabinet de guerre c'est
totalement inimaginable dans le contexte
c'est tout à fait imaginable c'est
imaginable imaginable et nécessaire ouis
et c'est la seule issue pour pour
arrêter euh pour pour arrêter cette
cette guerre ce que veut Israël la
destruction du du ramas on en parlera
plus tard est impossible il y a pas de
solution militaire euh au conflit Israël
au palalestinien par contre ce que veut
Israël aujourd'hui c'est retrouver les
237 otages qui se trouvent euh dans les
mains du Hamas et Israël je peux vous le
dire de très bonnes sources est prête à
libérer les presque 6000 prisonniers
palestiniens en Israël y compris et moi
je je suis tout à fait euh positif dans
ce sens un des leaders palestiniens qui
s'appelle Marwan bargouti donc qui est
en prison depuis 20 prison depuis 20 ans
euh donc moi je pense que ça peut être
une solution pour sortir de cette
situation catastrophique pour les uns
comme pour les autres il faut libérer
les prisonniers il faut libérer les
otages personne ne sait ce qui se passe
avec les otages est-ce qu'ils sont vie
qui est on vie donc c'est c'est c'est
très très dur pour les familles mais
après la guerre s'arrête je pense que
s'il y a une libération de d'otage la
guerre s'arrête le conflit ne s'arrête
pas malheureusement mais mais a
aujourd'hui j'espère moi je pense que
dans chaque prix je suis un optimiste
que dans chaque crise il y a aussi des
opportunités peut-être que après cette
catastrophe qu'on a jamais vécu il y a
des opportunités pour remettre remettre
de la sagesse sur la table et remettre
les belligérants autour d'une table pour
négocier un accord de paix beaucoup plus
global mais pour l'instant la
communication très officielle du Premier
ministre israélien c'est refus de tout
cesser le feu on l'out écoute il utilise
des références historiques et bibliques
c'est
nouveau je tiens à préciser la position
d'Israël concernant le cesser le feu
tout comme les États-Unis n'ont pas
accepté de cesser le feu après le
bombardement de perlarbor ou après
l'attaque terroriste du 11 septembre
Israël n'acceptera pas de cesser les
hostilités avec le Hamas après les
horribles attaques du 7
octobre
les appels au cess le feu sont des
appels à la capitulation d'Israël devant
le Hamas devant le terrorisme devant la
barbarie cela n'arrivera pas mesdames et
messieurs la Bible dit qu'il y a un
temps pour la paix et un temps pour la
guerre nous sommes en temps de
guerre Pascal Boniface ce temps de
guerre peut-il durer longtemps est-ce
qu'il y a une stratégie de de Benyamin
netania du cabinet de guerre aujourd'hui
il y a une action mais je crois pas
qu'il a une stratégie une stratégie on
se donne des moyen pour parenir à une
fin là la fin annoncée c'est la
destruction du Hamas ce n'est pas
possible matériellement politiquement on
peut pas détruire ou alors on tue non
pas des milliers mais des dizaines de
milliers de Palestiniens donc c'est
aussi l'idéologie le Stup idéologie et
puis en plus et puis même si on détruit
ce mouvement si rien n'est fait
politiquement d'autres renîtront
peut-être pire encore et cetera c'est ce
qui manque c'est quelle perspective
politique il a à part tirer bombarder
faire des M
aggraver la situation et lui qui se
réfère effectivement à ce qu'on fait les
États-Unis après parB et surt après le
11 septembre Biden lui-même a dit
que on s'est trompé on a réagit trop
avec la force on n pas fait de politique
on a réagi avec la force et on a plongé
le monde dans un chos indescriptible
pour plusieurs années ne faites pas la
même erreur et en faitam dit je vais
faire la même erreur mais ça s'explique
peut-être par le Traumat me vécu par la
société israélienne est-ce qu'on peut
effectivement comparer le 7 octobre à 11
septembre 2001 pour les Américains x 10
ouais x 10 en septembre c'était une
catastrophe qui a bouleversé le monde on
a vu les méf au Moyen-Orient on a vu les
méf l'Afghanistan aujourd'hui on voilà
on a vu les mfet en Irak ça a été ça ça
a changé l'ordre du Moyen-Orient en
mal mais pour la société isralienne est
complètement traumatisée euh je crois
que c'est un choc qu'elle n'a jamais
vécu jamais jamais vécu c'est la
première fois qu'il y a des attaques sur
le terrain israélien que des que des
terroristes rentrent en Israël et et
l'attaque d'une façon si cruelle et si
massive et le paradoxe qui me fait
beaucoup de peine en tant que militant
pour la paix c'est que la plupart des
victimes du côté israélien appartiennent
au comp de la paix ils ont pas attaqué
des soldats ils ont pas attaqué des
colons ils ont attaqué des gens qui tous
les jours avaient des contacts avec les
Gazaouis qui faisaient des choses je
parlais hier à un père d' d'une fille
qui a été
tuée dans le dans le sud d'Israël c'est
un homme qui travaille avec les
Palestiniens tous les jours qui
transporait les Palestiniens dans les
hôpitaux israéliens tous les jours et ce
que j'ai trouvé admirable il m'a
beaucoup aimu il m'a dit au faire je
vais pas arrêter ma fille est morte mais
moi je je sais que le Rama c'est pas les
Palestiniens ce cet homme d'affaire et
alman qui est un des premiers qui qui
ont qui employé 200 200 Palestiniens
dans Gaza dans le hightech dans les
mêmes conditions de travail qui donnit
oui don en donant des salaires
équivalents équivalents aux Israéliens
et sa fille est morte avec son futur
gendre et et et et valman dit non moi je
vais pas seulement ne pas arrêter
d'empocher des palestinens gaz mais je
vais doubler le nombre de Palestiniens
donc ça ça fait de la peine que ce soit
eux qui ont qui ét touchés mais mais que
pe-t-il aujourd'hui dans la dans la dans
la société israélienne finalement c'est
la peine est pas audible aujourd'hui
ouais euh même le camp de la paix ne
veut pas en parler on est soit dans la
dans la paralysie dans la dépression
soit dans dans la dans la rage dans la
volonté de vengeance dans les deux cas
c'est pas bon donc j'espère que les
jours prochains les la raison reviendra
et qu'on comprenne que il y a aussi de
l'autre côté des victimes on ne peut pas
pardonner le massacre de du se octobre
par ces terroristes euh qui sont les
ennemis du peuple palestinien ils
savaiit qu'Israël allait réagir de cette
façon Israël réagit toujours d'une
façon très très dure donc le Hamas
voulait qu'Israël réagisse il voulait le
chaos il voulait qu'on voie à la
télévision maintenant les victimes
Palestiniens c'est les ennemis des
Palestiniens c'est les ennemis de
l'Islam c'est lesem em du monde arabe
d'ailleurs partout un peu partout dans
le monde arabe les Frères musulmans on
est en train de les de les chasser du
pouvoir en Tunisie au Maroc on a vu en
Égypte parce que leur ambition elle est
pas il représente pas le peuple
palestinien le Hamas c'est c'est le
mouvement de résistance islamique c'est
le c'est pas le drapeau palestinien
c'est le drapeau vert donc le leur
objectif c'est un califat c'est autre
chose Alexandre
schb effectivement il y a cet objectif
affiché par par netaniaou É radiquer le
Hamas on est je pense à peu près tous
d'accord pour dire que c'est que c'est
impossible l'armée israélienne qui
annonce que plusieurs chefs de de la
branche armée ont été ont été tués euh
est-ce qu'est-ce qu'on peut dire ce soir
d'une éventuelle fragilisation du ramas
ma question est pas simple je suis pas
sûr que vous ayez la réponse mais parce
que personne personne n' vraiment la
réponse il y a en effet des leaders des
leaders qui qui sont tués il y a des
hommes du Hamas qui sont tués peut-être
des hommes qui ont qui ont qui sont
entrés en Israël qui ont commis cet
épouvantable massacre le 7 octobre mais
comme le disait Pascal Boniface comme le
dit très bien au fer bnstein aussi
euh c'est c'est c'est totalement
d'autres d'autres arriveront après tous
ces enfants qui qui qui voient leurs
parents leurs frères leur s tuer n envie
c'est c'est à nouveau de tuer alors il y
a deux choses sur lesquelles je voudrais
revenir qui sont intéressantes euh le
vide stratégique euh de netanahou enfin
du gouvernement israélien c'est vrai que
je pense qu'il ne sait absolument pas
quel sera le coup d'après si je puis me
permettre de prononcer ce mot mais
euh mais c'est peut-être une chance
finalement parce que c'est peut-être ça
qui va permettre si les leaders mondiaux
sont sont un peu de de dans de de de de
plom dans la tête et de courage surtout
courage c'est peut-être ce qui va
permettre de remplir ce vide avec un
vrai projet parce que je pense que tout
le monde a tellement peur en ce moment
vraiment je pense que c'est euh dans le
monde entier je crois qu'il y a pas un
endroit au monde où on ne soit pas
touché par ce conflit où on n pas peur
euh il y a qu'à voir ce qui s'est passé
au Dagestan très loin de de de de
TelAviv de Paris de Londres et donc tout
le monde a tellement peur et je pense
les leaders du monde entier aussi que
qu'ils soient arabe parce qu'ils savent
que le leurs populations sont sont très
sensibles au sort des Palestiniens
qu'ils soient occidentaux parce qu'il
voit bien que là ils sont ils sont
entraînés dans sa f folie guerrière par
netanahou entraîné dans le dans le vide
dans le gouffre donc tout le monde a
peur et je pense j'espère que le fait
qu'il a un vide stratégique il a un vide
politique même parce que netanahou les
Israéliens ne veulent plus en entendre
pas parler donc ce gouvernement ne ne va
pas survivre donc il y a tout à
reconstruire il y a tout à reconstruire
alors évidemment ce n'est pas au non
israélien de décider pour Israël mais
avec avec un peu de comme dit offer
beaucoup de courage de bonne volonté de
de de d'imagination d'espoir il y a
quelque chose à faire il faut absolument
bâtir sur cette tragédie quelque chose
qui tienne la route le problème c'est
que depuis 20 ans on a totalement fermé
les yeux sur ce qui s'est passé parce
que c'est CIT on pensait qu'il y avit
pas de solution enfin voilà et ça c'est
c'est peut-être le seul espoir deuxième
petite chosey la référence à la Bible en
effet je pense que c'est assez nouveau
et ça je crains que ce soit l'influence
de des des camarades de jeu de de de
Benyamin netaniaou les religieux qui
prenait de plus en plus d'importance
dans la vie politique israélienne et ça
c'était dramatique et et on voit comme
il a été contaminé si je puis dire par
ça puisque c'est assez nouveau c'est
assez nouveau qu'il qu'il qu'il prononce
Pascal Boniface sur le euh l'hypothèse
de voir une initiative internationale se
se lever dans les prochains alors je
sais pas dire jours ou semaines euh
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez bah
l'histoire monte qu'il faut attendre un
certain nombre de morts avant que les
pays occidentaux se réveillent et
demandent à Israël d'arrêter on l'a vu
en 2006 2009 2012 2014 et pour l'instant
ils sont tétanisés parce que
effectivement ils ont un peu peur que
leur image il y a quand même ce
sentiment que l'Ouest est de plus en
plus critiqué au sud h il y a ce fossé
entre l'Ouest et le reste que les pays
du Sud disent mais vous vous critiquez
la Russie quand elle bombarde l'Ukraine
vous ne critiquez pas Israël quand il de
Gaza alors on peut discuter sur les
comparaisons mais en toutous les cas
cette perception est une réalité dans de
nombreux pays et donc en fait on voit
bien que y compris les États-Unis ont
peur d'être entraîné dans l'impopularité
par indirectement par rapport à Israël
et que l'impopularité d'Israël dans le
monde affecte également les pays
occidentaux et puis ça dans la gestion
de ce qui est pour eux l'affaire la plus
importante c'était la guerre
Russie-Ukraine et tout ceci vient
perturber en donnant un peu d'espace à
Poutine qui peut dire regardez moi je
suis un homme de paix regardez comment
ça se passe là-bas et cetera donc en
fait mais c'est vrai que pour l'instant
aucun pays aucun leader occidental ne se
sent en mesure de dicter des conditions
à netanyahù y compris le président
américain il a pu peut-être juste faire
retarder l'offensive tant qu'il soit en
visite dans la région mais regardez le
que quand même que le roi de Jordanie
que le président égyptien ne disent
c'est pas le moment qu'on soit pris en
photo avec le président américain en dit
quand même long sur la peur qu'ils ont
de leur propre opinion publique c'était
après le bombardement de l'hôpital
c'était le contexte était différ c'était
mais il y a quand même un climat général
où ces régimes qui sont aussi fragiles
en fait ils ont peur que des critiques
de leur complicité avec les États-Unis
qui est lié à Israël entraînent des
révoltes qui puissent fragiliser leur
propre régime et donc en fait la
question tous ces régimes sont fragiles
aussi bien en Israël que dans les pays
voisins et tout le monde a un peu peur
mais pour l'instant une fois encore
disons que les israens disent personne
ne fait pression sur nous c'est nous qui
décidons de la façon donè la guerre et
personne ne dit non on vous fournit
l'aide et donc on peut vous donner
quelques indications on parle de
l'opinion palestinienne dans un instant
vous êtes pas tout à fait d'accord fr
exactement la la l'analyse de de Pascal
parce que je contrairement à lui j'ai vu
des des des sondages aujourd'hui auprès
des des démocrates américains ouis il ne
soutiennent pas euh Biden et il ne
soutiennent pas les attaques
israéliennes euh à Gaza donc dans son
propre parti à une année é l'autorité
étatique a pas de pression de la
diplomatie américaine pour dire vous
savez Biden les Israéliens sont tombés
amoureux parce qu'il a fait le
grand-père il est venu passer quelques
heures en Israël il a montré sa
compassion et son émotion mais il a rien
proposé il a rien proposé les Américains
et les Européens ne proposent rien ils
se réveillent en état de crise ils
réagissent quand il y a quelques
mortsord il réagisse un peu plus parce
que c'est une catastrophe mais il ne se
donne pas les moyens vous savez les
Israéliens c'est Kissinger qui l'avait
dit n'ont pas de politique extérieure
ils ont que de la politique intérieure
et nataniao est pris comme tous les
gouvernements précédents est pris en
otage par ses propres coalitions donc
chacun se tient de l'autre côté il
n'arrive pas à à avoir une vision euh on
dit que un politicien c'est quelqu'un
qui regarde les prochaines élections un
homme d'État c'est quelqu'un qui regarde
les prochaines génération euh la
l'Europe a donné 50 milliards d'euros en
moins de 20 30 ans à à l'Autorité
palestinienne dans la vision qu'un État
palestinien va naître et ils n'ont pas
son leur mot à dire l'Europe est le
principal marché d'Israël et le
principal il n'a rien à dire il faut
maintenant je veux je dis pas imposer
mais je crois qu'il faut dire aux
belligérant basta vous nous avez fatigué
vous mettez en danger nos vies ici à
Paris vous mettez en danger les régimes
de vos de vos voisins c'est ça la
solution c'est la solution des deux
états il faut il faut il faut arrêter le
carnage nous on vous l'impose on vous
l'impose on vous encourage je sais pas
la bonne terminologie mais être beaucoup
plus virulent beaucoup plus déterminé et
beaucoup plus courageux que pensent les
les Palestiniens du ramas on va essayer
de se concentrer sur cette question dans
dans notre débat pour l'instant ce qu'on
entend les uns et les autres le plus
massivement évidemment dans dans les
médias français et occidentaux ce sont
des habitants de la bande de Gaza qui
sont écrasés par les bombardements je
vous propose un témoignage il s'appelle
Sami alzar il est habitant à Gaza
réveillé en pleine nuit par une frappe
aérienne sur son
immeuble
ils ont tiré la roquette sans aucun
avertissement nous étions endormis et
nous nous sommes réveillés quand elle a
frappé nous nous sommes retrouvés dans
les décombr de la maison certains ont
été blessés et je pense que cinq enfants
et trois femmes ont été
tués et on va avec vous Steve Jourdain
essayer de de comprendre de sonder
presque le l'opinion palestinienne c'est
pas si facile parce que depuis le 7
octobre évidemment on parle du jour
d'après vous vous êtes allé un peu en
avant jant avant le 7 octobre attentat
terroriste la très sérieuse revue
amerricaine Foreign Affairs a publié un
sondage sur ce que pensent précisément
les Gazaouis de l'organisation islamiste
alors on rappelle que le Hamas est au
pouvoir dans l'enclave depuis les
législativees de 2006 et la guerre CIV
civile qui a suivi l'étude a donc été
réalisée 17 ans après juste avant les
attentats enquête réalisée en
partenariat avec le baromètre arabe un
réseau de recherche indépendant sur le
Moyen-Orient plusieurs centaines
d'entretiens ont été menés entre le 28
septembre et le 6 octobre auprès de la
population Gazaoui h et les
enseignements vous allez nous les
détailler ils sont vraiment intéressants
oui très intéressants on apprend
qu'entre les Gazaoui et le Hamas la
rupture est très très nette une majorité
de sondé 44 % affirment n'avoir aucune
confiance dans l'organisation islamiste
23 % disent n'avoir qu'une confiance
modérée not lot of trust seulement 29 %
des Gazaouis reconnaissent faire
confiance au Hamas certains évidemment
refusent de répondre autre donnée
intéressante Thomas quand on leur
demande si leurs difficultés économiques
et sociales sont dues au blocus
israélien en vigueur depuis 2007 une
majorité d'entrees disent que c'est pas
forcément la raison principale ils
rejetteent la faute sur le Hamas et sa
mauvaise gestion à 31 % 26 % mett en
cause l'inflation et seulement 16 % des
Gazaouis imputent la responsabilité de
la situation au blocus israélien et puis
alors ce qui ressort aussi autre élément
passionnant un désir exprimé de
changement politique oui un vrai désir
de Chang chement seulement une minorité
d'entrex pense que les les autorités
actuelles répondent aux préoccupations
de la population 23 % contre 45 % qui
considèrent que ce n'est pas le cas le
problème c'est qu'ils ne savent pas
comment faire remonter ses
préoccupations pour influer sur les
choix de leur leader pour 68 % des
Gazaoui le droit de participer
pacifiquement à une manifestation n'est
pas garantie dans l'enclave une majorité
de Gazaoui considère enfin que rien
n'est efficace pour peser sur la ligne
du Hamas et dans ce sondage j'ai réalisé
je rappelle avant le le 7 octobre
comment voit-il l'après al complètement
différemment eu du Hamas on leur a
présenté trois scénarios pour la
résolution du conflit Israël au
palalestinien avec la possibilité de
choisir une une 4èe option pas vraiment
formulée hein la fameuse vous savez le
le le carré autre la majorité d'entre
eux sont favorables à la solution à deux
états 54 % donc deux états un État juif
un état palestinen vivant côte à côte ce
soutien ne varie pas à côté gazaou
puisqu'il a été plus ou moins identique
lors d'un précédent sondage réalisé en
2021 10 % sont en faveur d'une
confédération israëlpalestinienne et 9 %
des sondés sont pour un état unique dans
lequel on retrouverait des juifs et des
Palestiniens je termine avec un chiffre
important Thomas 73 % des Gazaouis
affirment être en faveur d'un règlement
pacifique du conflit en contradiction
totale donc avec le Hamas qui souhaite
tout simplement la
destruction d'Israël la question
maintenant bien c'est de savoir si la
guerre va rebattre toutes ces cartes
évidemment merci beaucoup Steve Jord
c'était passionnant de d'avoir les
résultats de ce sondage Alexandra
Schwarzbrot que on peut imaginer que les
les 25 jours de de bombardement
israélien ont changé la donne ou pas
peut-être d'ailleurs encore que c'est ce
que j'ais dire non pas pas forcément
c'est plutôt ça c'est c'est bien ça
donne un peu un peu d'espoir de lire ce
ce sondage alors ce qui est intéressant
aussi ce qui va être très intéressant à
suivre aussi euh c'est ce qui se passe
en si Jordanie parce que là on parle
énormément de Gaza alors le fait qu'en
effet les les les la population de gaz
soit plutôt réticente face au Hamas elle
qui vit sous son jou sous son contrôle
depuis depuis toutes ces années et est
plutôt très intéressante en sijordanie
le problème c'est qu'il y a des colons
qui qui qui qui qui se livre à des
exactions terribles sur les Palestiniens
ah mais il y a eu plus de 100 morts en 2
semaines et qui qui leur arrache les
oliviers qui rentrent dans leur maison
en les jetant dehors en leur disant
maintenant ici c'est chez moi tu t'en
vas et donc là j'ai très peur que
paradoxalement ce soit en 6 Jordanie que
ça se durcisse que que ça s'embrase
carrément et que et et là alors là s'il
y a deux fronts à mener ça va être ça va
être compliqué on va y revenir plus
longuement sur la situation en S
Jordanie si vous le voulez bien mais je
reste sur l'opinion palestinienne à Gaza
Pascal
Boniface on peut imaginer aussi c'est ce
que c'est ce que vous laissiez entendre
que les Palestiniens qui sont sous les
bombes depuis plus de 3 semaines
enveuille aussi au Hamas oui parce que
enfin ils ils peuvent enloir au Hamas
déjà pour avant parce que je dire c'est
quand même une dictature il y a pas de
liberté et donc le jou du Hamas c'est
quand même imposant et donc c'est un jou
qui s'impose il y a un blocus et un jou
de l'autorité compétente sur le
territoire donc et le Hamas n'a pas
délivré ce qu'il devait délivrer donc il
y a pas une très grande confiance le
problème aussi jordanis c'est que
l'autorité palestienne est encore plus
discrédité que la Hamas parce qu'elle
est corrompue parce que la la
proposition c'est en négociant avec les
palestin avec l'Israélien qu'on
obtiendra quelque chose ils n'ont
absolument rien obtenu en 20 ans c'est
un échec total et ce qu'ils ont obtenu
c'est de coopérer parce que malgré les
différentes menaces mahoudabbas fait une
coopération sécuritaire avec Israël qui
est vécu comme une sorte d'occupation
interne par les Palestiniens donc le
Hamas est impopulaire à Gaza mais
l'Autorité palestinienne est totalement
impopulaire et donc par réaction comme
les ne subissent pas le jou du Hamas il
ils sont pas soumis à la f du Hamas ils
peuvent se dire ah bah au moins eux ils
combattent au moins et être pris donc il
peut avoir une certaine popularité mais
offert a parlé tout à l'heure de la
libération de prisonniers beaucoup
d'observateurs pensent qu'il y a
quelqu'un qui incarne une alternative
qui est en prison depuis 20 ans qui a
été condamné pour terrorisme alors qu'il
clame son innocence qui est partisan
d'un accord négocié avec Israël et qui
lui est légitime parce que bah depuis 20
ans qu'il est en prison il est pas
corrompu c'est bon voilà il en avit fait
avant c'est Marwan margouti que les
Israéliens ont toujours refusé de
libérer est-ce que les choses changer
parce fait quand je pense à son hisire
je pense à celle de Nelson Mandela oui
alors je sa certainement c'est pas
totalement comparable mais c'est un
homme qui sort de prison et qui
finalement décide de pardonner entre
guillemets d'incarner la paix et donc
effectivement c'est il y a on faire
comparaison et là il y aura vraiment un
mir parce que je ve dire le Hamas on
peut pas négocier avec et je suis pas
sûr qu'il ve négocier l'Autorité
palestinienne les dirigeants du monde
entier les G occidentaux font semblant
de croire encore qu'il représente
quelque chose mais il y a quand qu même
un marché de DUP d'aller voir mabouabbas
en disant que c'est représentant mais
qui représente les Palestiniens c'est
pas l'utorité palestinenne c'est pas le
Hamas donc il y a un vide
stratosphérique qu'il faut remplir faute
de quoi déjà que les Israéliens au
pouvoir ne veulent pas une solution
politique mais on ne sait pas trop avec
qui il a négocié pour l'instant parce
que l'idée de dire qu'on va rétablir
l'autorité palestinine à Gaza pourner
les CL du pouvoir après des
bombardements israéliens si l'autorité
paltienne revient dans les fourgons de
l'armée israélienne ça ne marchera pas
c'est pas la solution proposée par par
le président Macron non euh et c'est une
solution proposée par certains
Israéliens oui mais ça elle aurait dû
être proposé quand quand les Israéliens
ont quitté d'une façon unilatérale Gaza
et et par Charon Israël aurait dû dès le
départ avait dit en fait j Belline avait
dit à l'époque qui était le leader du
Meret le parti à gauche du parti trist
si on se retire de Gaza sans négocier
avecautorité palestinienne c'est le
Hamas qui va gagner mais mais vous savez
nataniao lui-même l'extrême droite
israélienne et le ministre des finan et
encore 2 mois a dit si on ne veut pas
d'état palestinien il faut renforcer le
Hamas donc c'est la politique de
l'extrême droite israélienne était de
diviser pour régner et de dire on n pas
de partenaire palestinien je partage pas
exactement ton ton avis par rapport à
l'autorité palestinienne parce que parce
que l'autorité palestinenne c'est pas
Mahmoud Abbas si moi si j'ai une lueur
d'espoir aussi au niveau politique c'est
que dans 6 mois la scène politique
isralen et palestiniennne va être
complètement modifié euh Natania est sur
le départ son gouvernement neous sera
pas le prochain gouvernement n'aura pas
la même forme il y aura des élections ou
pas forcément en Israël il y aura il y
aura des élections parce que je ne vois
pas un autre gouvernement avec cette
coalition se foré mais Israël comme vous
le savez ces dernières années a pris
l'habitude d'avoir des
élections récurrentes Mahmoud Abbas va
partir c'est une question de mois
aujourd'hui on le maintient pour éviter
une guerre de de succession à
l'intérieur de l'autorité moi je l'aime
beaucoup c'est un ami mais c'est fini
donc je crois que avant l'été il va
avoir des changements politiques très
très important chez les Israéliens et
chez les Palestiniens et c'est
l'occasion encore une fois pour la
communauté internationale d'être ferme
déterminée et courageuse pour les
pousser à une solution permanente du
conflit je vis qu'on parle effectivement
de la S Jordanie vous avez commencé à
l'évoquer mais on va y consacrer
quelques quelques minutes dans ce débat
avec peut-être pour commencer la
communication officielle de l'armée
israélienne le porte-parole de de tsal
alors quand il parle de Jordanie il
parle de la Judée et de la Samarie pour
que vous compreniez bien le l'extr voilà
c'est une autre rétorique on écoute cet
extrait tôt le matin en Judée et en
Samarie notre armée a éliminé un certain
nombre de terroristes dans le camp de
réfugiés de Jenine il s'agissait de
terroristes armés engagés contre nos
forces ils ont été éliminés depuis les
aires parallèlement cette nu encore des
dizaines d'activistes terroristes ont
été arrêtés rejoignant ainsi les plus de
700 agents du Hamas arrêtés en Judée et
en Samarie depuis le début de la guerre
et selon le ministère de la de la santé
en en palestinien en Jordanie au moins
122 Palestiniens ont été tués depuis le
le 7 octobre Alexandra schzbord vous
libération travaille beaucoup sur sur la
s-jordanie vous avez beaucoup documenté
ce qui s'y passe qu'est-ce que vous
pouvez nous en dire ben que l'ambiance
est totalement pesante les gens sont
enfermés les Palestiniens sont enfermés
chez
eux parce qu'ils ont peur ils ont peur
d'être d'être agressés par les colons
ils ont peur que les soldats les
prennent pour des des terroristes du
Hamas donc ils sont ils sont planqués
ils ont peur du ramas aussi et ils ont
peur aussi sans doute du parce qu'ils
veulent pas dénoncer le drame du 7
septembre c'est ça qui m'inquiète à moi
7 octobre le 7 octobre ils veulent pas
le dénoncer parce qu'ils ont peur de
ramas oui non mais il y a une peur il y
a je crois qu'on Nimagine pas le le le
la peur qui qui qui règne en sjordanie
et à Jérusalem est là aussi on parle on
parle on parle pas beaucoup de la S
jourordanie mais on parle encore moins
de Jérusalem Est qui est donc la partie
autrefois palestinienne de de Jérusalem
mais qui de moins en moins puisque la
plupart des Palestiniens on été on ont
été chassés de Jérusalem donc on on en
parle moins mais alors eux ils ont
encore plus peur donc eux ils sont les
les Palestiniens de Jérusalem Est sont
vraiment enfermés chez eux ils n'osent
pas sortir ils ont peur des soldats et
des colons et sans doute de alors ben
justement euh vous dites ils ont peur du
harama c'estàdire que les Palestiniens
qui pourraient dire c'est un
insupportable ce qui s'est passé le 7
octobre et condamné clairement euh
l'attaque terroriste n'ose pas le faire
c'est enfin pour beaucoup d'entre ça
c'est quelque chose qui personnellement
me touche énormément je veux pas dire me
décevoir parce que je ne veux pas être à
leur place mais ça m'a fait de la peine
de voir des des mes partenaires depuis
depuis 30 ans 40 ans pour la paix pas
seulement des partenaires pour la paix
des amis personnels des gens avec qui
j'étais j'ai vu leurs enfants naître
j'étais chez eux à la maison ils étaient
chez moi et de de ne pas vouloir
condamner le la catastrophe du du 7
octobre alors ils sont dans une
schizophrénie d'un côté ils sont fiers
d'avoir vu Israël à genoux parce que
c'est une vengance parce qu'ils ont
compris aussi
que la résistance pacifique n'a pas
fonctionné on a vu comment on a
marginalisé et affaibli l'Autorité
palestinienne à parce qu'on le voulait
et d'un autre côté il ils
sont il condamne cette catastrophe
condamne je parlais aujourd'hui à une
ami à moi qui qui é une organisation
Franco israelllo Jordano palestinen qui
s'appelle les copis elle s'appelle nada
c'est une femme remarquable laïque
militante elle elle a retiré ces
derniers jours ça s'appelle eopis ses
bureau à ramala elle a retiré le PCE
elle a laissé le elle me dit offire il
me menace il me menace parce que je fais
de la normalisation avec les Israéliens
il me menace parce que je parle avec des
Israéliens il me menace parce qu'on fait
des projets avec les Israéliens
aujourd'hui je je suis obligé de retirer
le PCE et je ne peux pas condamner ce
qu'ils ont fait donc le mot paix la met
en danger aujourd'hui le mot paix met en
danger parce que ça veut dire
collaboration avec les Israéliens ça
veut dire normalisation ça ça me choque
parce que j'aurais voulu qu'il condamne
le 7 octobre ils auraient gagné du des
points dans l'opinion publique israen et
international et ils ont du mal à le
faire mais mais j'allais dire je peux
les comprendre mais j'ai du mal à
comprendre ceux qui ne condamn pas les
massacres du 7 octobre et qu'il condamn
Israël tant qu'ils le veulent et ils ont
de très bonnes raisons de le faire mais
il faut condamner le 7 octobre aussi h
létitien on va parler de des actes
antisémites en France pu que l'une des
questions l'une des craintes depuis le 7
octobre c'est évidemment le
l'importation du du conflit il y a un
nombre d'actes antisémites en France en
augmentation et ce qui nous intéresse
c'est la réponse du gouvernement elle
est simple he Thomas elle est répatié
par tous les ministres qu's on
l'occasion c'est fermeté la plus totale
et d'ailleurs le gouvernement vous
pouvez remarquer communique beaucoup sur
le sujet hier c'était le ministre de
l'Intérieur Gérald armanin qui lui même
a donné le nombre d'actes antisémit
depuis le 7 octobre c'est un nombre en
hausse vous avez raison puisque nous
sommes à 819 actes qui ont été recensés
une hausse considéble juste pour vous
donner comme ça un autre chiffre qui va
pouvoir permettre la comparaison 2015
c'est l'année la pire de la décennie en
nombre d'actes antisémiques on était à
anite on était à 808 actes en une année
complète en une année vous avez vu
depuis le 7 octobre on a dépassé le
nombre d'une année mais au gouvernement
la position est très claire c'est-à-dire
que on fait la transparence sur le
nombre d'actes antisémites et
immédiatement il faut toujours donner le
nombre d'interpellations c'est-à-dire
qu'il faut montrer qu'il y a une
réaction immédiate de l'État français et
donc hier Gérald amanin le ministre de
l'Intérieur a dit 819 actes antisémite
et
414 interpellations il a aussi donné le
nombre de policiers qui sont déployés et
gendarmes hein pour euh protéger les
Juifs de France 11000 autour des lieux
de culte des écoles des lieux dit
communautaire et d'ailleurs le le
message du du ministre de l'intérieur
était assez calibré hier il s'est
adressé aux Juifs de France en disant
n'ayez pas peur c'est normal que vous
ayez peur je le comprends mais la
République va vous protéger le
gouvernement qui communique également
sur autour des peines de justice oui
c'est le garde des saut Éric Dupont
Moretti qui a demandé au procureur
d'être très sévère il l'a fait savoir et
qui communique sur les peines alors
parfois 8 mois avec surci 6 mois avec
surcis il y a aussi des assignations en
résidence avec un bracelet électronique
et il a aussi dévoilé que plus de 200
enquêtes étaient en cours autour des
faits d'antisémitisme et d'apologie du
terrorisme et il y a aussi une
communication qui est faite Thomas sur
la la haine en ligne ouis ça c'est la
dilcra la délégation interministériale à
la lutte contre le racisme
l'antisémitisme et la haine antillgbt
qui communique donc et elle a déjà
effectué dit-elle des centaines de
signalements et jusqu'où va cette
transparence est-ce que le gouvernement
détaille ces faits antisémites pas
vraiment mais ce matin à la sortie du
Conseil des ministres le porte-parole du
gouvernement Olivier verérrant en a
dressé une liste générale écoutez-le
mais on parle d'antisémitisme madame
ou quel type de réponse voudriez-vous
qu'on adopte si ce n'est la fermeté à
l'encontre de ceux qui tiennent des
propos antisémite qui vont taguer des
croix des étoiles de David sur les
portes des gens qui menacent à tel
enseigne des populations des des
Français parce qu'ils sont de confession
juive que ceuxci hésitent parfois à
sortir de chez eux à mettre leurs
enfants à l'école la fermeté bien sûr
est la réponse qui convient dans ce type
de situation la fermeté la plus extrême
la plus totale aucune impunité ne serait
tolérée aucune impunité c'est le message
du président de la République c'est
message qu'il a fait passer à tous les
ministères avec un mot d'ordre ne rien
laisser passer fer branstein c'est vous
dites c'est terrible c'est je vous
entendais réagir pendant la chronique de
l' C derniers jours on m' demander moi
je suis juif et vous savez les Juifs sur
leurs porte ils ont une mesousa donc
c'est c'est visible pour la première
fois de ma vie on m'a demandé de la
retirer et ça je ne l'accepterai jamais
vous des amis non c'est pas les
autorités qui mont demandé des amis des
amis qui disent protège-toi retirre
atttion c'est pas le moment moi je crois
je je je ne le ferai pas mais le fait
qu'on me le dit c'est c'est c'est
frrayant par rapport à l'antisémitisme
permettez-moi de de de remarques la
première c'est que je pense que beaucoup
de ces pro Palestiniens entre guillemets
même proamas entre guillemets sont
instrumentalisés parce que je je je
déplore le fait que je ne les ai pas vu
dans les rues quand 500000 sirriens ont
été massacrés je ne les ai pas vu dans
les rues quand 1 million et demi de de
musulmans ont été tués dans la guerre
Irak Iran dans les années 80 je ne les
ai pas vu dans dans dans les rues quand
il y a des des musulmans qui se sont
fait massacré en Irak je les vois dans
la rue que lorsqu'il y a le conflit
Israël au palestinien et je le déplore
et la deuxième remarque donc ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire que sont là quand
il a Israël pour pouvoir exprimer un
antisémitisme ch absolument je pense que
les raisons sont mauvaises pour une
partie d'entre eux la deuxième remarque
je suis sollicité pour parler parfois du
processus de paix j'accepte d'aller que
dans les bons lieux à chaque fois que j
suis allé et je parle de 5 km de Paris à
chaque fois que je suis allé à la fin de
de mon intervention il y a toujours un
gamin ou une gamine qui sont venus voir
pour me dire vous savez monsieur c'est
la première fois qu'on rencontre un juif
et ça je trouve que c'est la
responsabilité de la République c'est la
République qui doit faire en sorte que
nous nous rencontrions que nous nous
connaissions que nous nous parlions
sinon on va continuer à avoir cette
catastrophe de
racismeislamophobie et d'antisémitisme
qui va gongrainer notre société c'est
pareil pour les Israéliens et les
Palestiniens depuis le 2è antifada la
loi israélienne interdit aux Israéliens
d'aller chez les Palestiniens et les
Palestiniens qui rentrent en Israël
c'est uniquement les les les les
ouvriers les travailleurs les pauvres
donc les Israéliens ne se parlent pas ne
se rencontrent pas ne se connaissent pas
et on peut pas faire la paix si on se
parle pas si on se touche pas si on se
compatit avec la la souffrance de
l'autre et et ça c'est de notre ressort
de de de pouvoir le changer en Israël le
le c'est ce que ce que ce que vous venez
de dire c'est c'est très intéressant
parce que surtout ce qui s'est passé
c'est que depuis la construction du mur
euh qui sépare la s-jordanie de de
d'Israël euh a a a a fait a fait en
sorte dans les esprits des Israël en que
le problème palestinien avait été
repoussé au-delà du Mur c'était il y av
plus de problème
palestinien que la communauté
internationale était un peu dans le même
état d'Es un peu aussi la communauté
internationale entre ceux qui étaient
enfermés à Gaza et ceux qui étaient de
l'autre côté du mur il y avait plus de
problème Palestiniens et c'est ça le
drame et et en effet il n'y avait plus
de de d'aller et venu entre entre tel VI
ver ramala les gens ne se rencontraient
plus il y avait plus de génération qui
plus rien d'humain et c'est ça qui et et
c'est ça le drame les aînés les aînés
Israéliens Palestiniens avaient grandi
ensemble et se parlait de moi j'all de
fois deux fois par semaine trois fois
par semaine manger du poisson à Gaza com
mes amis appelai ça me prenait une heure
entre telavive et Gaza rien du tout pas
de Checkpoint rien on passait des
soirées fantastiques mais c'est vous
savez chez Gaza c'est encore pire comme
phénomène parce que les gazaou 1 il y a
très peu seulement ces derniers temps on
a autorisé un peu je vais je vais
excusez-moi l'expression mais les
Palestiniens de Gaza sont victimes d'un
viol collectif ils sont victimes du
ramas ils sont victimes d'Israël ils
sont victimes de l'Égypte ils sont
victimes du du du du du du monde arabe
tout le monde a utilisé les Gazaouis à
leur propres Séan pour leur propre
intérêt politique mais quand quand ça ça
arrive à l'aide et à la coopération ils
sont tous ils sont tous absents un
gazahoui la 50 75 % des gazahi ont moins
de 30 ans la plupart d'entre eux sont au
chômage on vit avec un dollar et demi à
Gaza ils sont souvent jamais sortis de
utor à rentr TR Israël c'estiquux qui
sont des donc il n jamais rien vu que
cette prison àouver qui est Gaza ils ne
connaissent pas l'autre il faut leur
ouvrir il faut leur permettre de
connaître le monde de s'ouvrir à l'autre
un mot de conclusion Pascal Boniface
est-ce que
effectivement on peut parce que
j'entendais ce que disaiter B votre côté
un peu optimiste qui ressortait en
disant peut-être que de ce chaos va
ressortir une nouvelle donne politique
des deux côtés ça vous semble réaliste
d'imaginer ça parce que l'histoire nous
nous nous prouve que bah pour l'instant
l'histoire éta dans côté depuis
l'assassinat de Rabine c'est Queen
Rabine a fait desrailler les du Hamas et
les assinraabin ont fait derrière le
processus de paix non il faut pas perdre
espoir il y a quand même toujour terror
il faut le dire oui bien sûr disons
d'entre guillemets descendants sont étit
au cabinet é au cabinet'entendait
auparavant juif Arab s'entit auparavant
ils ne sont pas condamnés à soir franç
allemand se sont réconciliés donc on
peut espérer mais s'il faut c'est une
volonté politique qui pour l'instantiste
pas pas mais avec un peu de volonté
politique effectivement il peut y avoir
une réconciliation mais c'est ça où la
catastrophe avec en plus des métastases
un peu partout ou mais volonté politique
intérieure ou ou alors l'initiative peut
venir de l'extérieur parce que c'est une
des grandes questions qu'on se pose
aujourdhui en fait si on pourra pas
l'imposer de l'extérieur mais si parce
que pour l'instant les Israéliens ont
pensaé queils s'étaient débarrassé les
Palestiniens il y avait pas de pression
extérieure que l'urope faisait pas
pressionun faisait pas pression donc ils
étaient ils étaient ils pensaient qu'il
qu' avaient résolu le problème bien sûr
que non ils ont pas résolu le problème
on fait la paix avec son ennemi pas avec
les gens ave qui on est pas en guerre et
donc il faut qu'il y ait de nouveau un
dialogue direct entre israélien
palestinien sauf que ceux qui sont aux
affaires pour l'instant ne sont pas
capables de se parler vous savez tout
dernier mot l'émission se termine on on
a toujours pensé que le paradigme
c'était négocié pour la création d'un
État palestinien moi je propose qu'on le
change il faut reconnaître un État
palestinien et après négocier les
frontières la capitale les réfugiés il
faut que la
communauté reconnaisse l'ét pales avant
toute discussion merci à tous d'avoir
participé à à ce débat qui était
passionnant Pascal Boniface votre livre
grat X2 grands enjeux du monde
contemporain publié aux éditions
d'uno pas d'émission demain pas de
matinale non plus jeudi noté Corian
Mancini reçoit Gill kepppel spécialiste
de l'islam et du monde arabe
contemporain et puis je vous dis à lundi
puisque je dis c'est Mathieu croissandau
qui sera à ma place qui présentera à
Sens public bonne soirée à toutes et à
tous